i like what this uh cyborg you know
cyborg yeah i've seen her actually
wearing hijab i don't know if you ever
seen her yeah saying masha allah you
know
and and and doing some really uh she she
actually um you know how
habib and this is what i kind of went
away from from um watching many of the
the uh ufcs and whatnot but what drew me
one time as i was
i was with uh my cousins and family were
they kept telling me about this this uh
muslim ufc guy
and
then i watched his fight one time and
what really you know
uh
touched me was when he stopped
afterwards and he thanked the almighty
he thanked the creator
[Applause]
without god we cannot do nothing
everything is nothing you know number
one
believe on your one god first of all
i want to say thank you for god
god is number one other things is
nothing alhamdulillah alhamdulillah you
know what it means
it's me me you know yeah and he made
sajdah he went and he prostrated you
know what i mean i was really impressed
with that you know what i mean and then
we see i don't know if they did this
before and again it goes back to like
people setting good trends she went out
she was feeding the poor yeah she's not
muslim she's christian but that's a good
thing we we commend that that's what we
need more of you know what i mean yeah
what do you what do you think yeah
exactly that was huge like after her
last fight she went out and i think she
uh she was at like ufc 200 something and
she went out and gave out like 200 meals
to kids and the poor people out there
and that's something that the ufc should
be promoting that's the things that
man that's that's just a beautiful thing
that she's going out there she's
promoting that and like you said it
could be every single fight giving us
thanks to giving us thanks 100 left for
everything and then even after his title
fight it's not me it's it's from god
that's what that's what that's what
right after his title that's what he's
got in a mic and i think that's going to
be huge that we got our first muslim
champion because it's going to show it's
going to put us in the limelight more
it's going to show like how muslims are
humble and like from when right now when
you look at the the news or anything
like that they're always showing shining
the light on all the negative things
that happen to muslims or guys that say
they're muslims and they're terrorists
and they're all of this and all that so
now
shine a light on a great muslim a great
humble muslim that's a champion that's a
real champion and he's still humble and
still not changing like conor mcgregor
where conor mcgregor got his money now
and he's becoming that villain now and
he doesn't care what people think of him
or it's he has that attitude like i'm
gonna do me no matter what i don't care
if i have kids looking up to me i don't
care if i i just had a kid i don't care
about any of that now i'm i'm still the
money maker and i'm still gonna be the
businessman that i want to be
uh khabib is more of a muslim before
he's a muslim before a businessman so
that's